greetings from podcast village Monday
November 5th [ __ ] wash your feet and
polish your [ __ ] toenails we're going
in deep
it's the murky water deep it's
Thanksgiving and then we roll on to
Christmas it's all over but the [ __ ]
Jean but anyway the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by
23andme 23andme is a personal generic
genetic service that helps you
understand what your DNA can tell you
about you and your family story as your
loved ones get together this
Thanksgiving discover more about the
genetic connections you share did you
inherit your you know whatever your
choice of law because of this from your
mom and your dad or how much it over
your DNA is compared to your brother or
your sisters all these things will be
answered with 23andme it's been named 23
pairs of chromosomes that make up our
DNA that's what its name from not do me
a favor now to Thanksgiving 23andme the
ancestry service kits are only $49 per
kid when you buy two or more kits it's
50% off the regular $99 this holiday so
get one for you one for your boyfriend
you're doing go to Thanksgiving nobody
knows you're half of Puerto Rican and
you're beautiful all right order your
23andme ancestry service kit at 23andme
comm slash church CH you are CH that's
the number 23andme calm slash Church CH
you are CH I did 23andme I found a bunch
of things are the beautiful people I
love to talk about the zip recruiting
you know I feel whether you have a small
business a big business you're not too
small you're not too big because zip
recruiter is there to help you okay
number one the job site send you tons of
the wrong resumes to sort out that's not
smart their job sites that make you wait
for the right candidates to apply for a
job that's not smart either
you know what smart is zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's a
powerful matching technology that scans
thousands of resumes identities people
with the right skills education and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply
so you get qualified candidates fast
that's why zip recruiter is number one
by employees so do me a favor right now
my listeners the church family
you can try zip recruiter for free for
free at zip recruiting Tom slash Church
again that zip recruiter dot-com slash
Church I don't care how big a business
how small you are I want you to have the
right employees so go to zip recruiter
dot-com slash Church and the church will
also like to bring back the famous you
ready for this one mission to achieve
calm it stay listen it's Thanksgiving
you don't want to show up at your
grandmother's with your [ __ ] smelling
like ten dead billy goats do you know
tushy calm is a portal for the dam but
day it's you know what I've smoked 22
joints already it's a portable the day
you would store yourself in less than
ten minutes I'm 300 pounds Lee I don't
know what it is your birthday still
working I use it every single day every
single [ __ ] day dependable they have
a good money they guarantee 60 day
you're not gonna need it if it could
hold my fat ask if you imagine what it
could do for your [ __ ] fat smelly ass
go to tissue calm right now and login
and mention the word muffler and get 10%
off who's better than tushy one more
time zip recruiting it one more time
23andme and one more time to pushy
kick that [ __ ] mule as to church
[ __ ] Monday morning let's pick this
right the [ __ ] up first off as you and I
both know Felicia Michaels welcome for
the show thank you that as a veteran
comic of twenty years hmm 50% of this
comedy journey is not the hard work you
put on the stage it's the relationships
outside of comedy and the adversities
that present themselves that's what
makes you a good comic that's a make
sure that plumber that should makes you
a good roofer that should make sure the
mechanic is - after 20 years you know
your craft so much that what's a pain in
the ass for somebody else you figure it
out that's what makes you good but in
this comedy journey the craziness is the
first 10 years and the stick that has to
be removed out of your ass
for you to become a successful comedian
because you have to go into areas that
you never dreamed of going to together
laughs you never dreamed of you know
that story you told me about sleeping
and Denis Leary's with the window broken
rain snow is coming through the window
you have to do things that are opposite
your comfort zone altogether absolutely
the point where you get creeped the [ __ ]
out you and homeland the conversation
before about the Comedy Store last year
at this time every time I go to Tammy's
gonna get carsick and then when I get to
the Comedy Store I have tons of anxiety
because I knew Mitzi and this is gonna
be in her and I told Brogan's and I'm in
town everybody ten years from now like
these idiots talk about Stanislavski and
this guy there's gonna be a Mitzi short
comedy guide line book that every time
it's gonna add one line to Beckham it's
he said to them one night on the way in
and how it applied to them that's the
book you know that's the book right and
it was so weird The Comedy Store
original room for me to get it laughs
and they're all I want until half I have
to go so far out of my comfort zone but
it disturbs me so I figured out after
going back to the notebooks at night and
reading you know because when I get home
and like to decompress I write my age I
forced myself to write a page sometimes
it's two pages and I read the discomfort
in my notes and it was I was being such
a [ __ ] because I knew it when you go to
the comments there you gotta go all in
you gotta go all the way right you gotta
fake the funk what do you got you got no
cards in your corner and you got ten
million you got to push that ten million
in you know I'm in and faking hopefully
the guy followed and look at you you
folded that's what it's like well I
remember when I was first at The Comedy
Store I think I became a regular in 1985
or 86 and prior used to come in and he
would go in on a Tuesday night and he
would be so [ __ ] terrible because
he's trying all new stuff but as a new
comic watching it and people would walk
out it would be so [ __ ] terrible and
you'd literally be like this is the
great Pryor
but just by being fortunate enough to be
at the Comedy Store and to see Tuesday
night then go back Wednesday night and
see him do the same material but tighten
it up and so it's not as bad
then go Thursday but just to see the
process of what Pryor did to get
something ready and that he had to
emotionally dig himself some big
fucked-up hole all the time to get to
that you know show on Friday night where
it was [ __ ] smooth as butter you know
nay mean like it was a process that it
that he did and to be able to see
someone like him do it it it gives you
comfort you know what I mean and I think
I when you're speaking about the bet the
half of the part of comedy that's not
just working on your act it is hanging
out with other people and seeing what
other people are struggling with or
seeing how other people are doing it and
sometimes you're not even ready to do it
like when I left comedy and came back I
took a class joke writing class with
Gabe Abelson I [ __ ] flappers right
just cuz I go on you you know my jokes
are kind of sloppy whatever and it
changed my life because he was like a
the head writer at Letterman for like
ten years but just but to learn they're
like real structure for how to write a
joke I don't necessarily do that all the
time but it totally changed my act and
it took how long to [ __ ] be able to
be open enough to listen to someone else
give advice you know but that's all the
process of it and the friendships you
make you know what I mean to think the
people you started out with how you
[ __ ] hated them or you had some
stupid-ass beef that twenty years later
those people are gonna be the people
that live give you a hand to lift you up
or you know what I mean say something so
kind when you thought they were being a
piece of [ __ ] and it was totally your
you know your self projecting but all of
that learning all of that poorly has to
go through it now I learned a lot you
know again I want to thank you people
who watch the special and the generous
and support me it's really weird the
reaction I've gotten from people like I
had a long conversation with Neal
Brennan
and I pulled him aside and told them
that you know between him and John
Mulaney that's what you aspire to be as
a comic you know real precise joke
writers
and when that right while that my
company's on sometimes I try to be like
those guys may eat a bag of dicks you
know and I told them that I go if I
wrote like you and then the other flip
side he goes if I could perform like you
then I said the [ __ ] anything I'm saying
so right everybody has holes in their
game everybody you know bring something
different to it bring something
different to the table
but it's so weird how we would just
laugh about something no no we just said
something at how we is in for the
journey of his life because Leesburg and
Leigh's very aunt you know and he asked
and he doesn't know that to fully emerge
yourself in the world of comedy it's you
go against you believe sometimes you go
against that stuff you learn when you
went to Israel little things that you
keep sacred you're gonna have to put
aside if not you're not gonna grow as
atomic things that you know might not
like to do things that it's it's so
weird how that part of the journey makes
you also like it it makes you also be
saying yes well you have to live your
life in order to report on your life yes
like sometimes it's comedy you can get
so anal and so into it and so I just
want to do this that you put your
personal life to the side but you have
to live your life I'm gonna hate to be
lame like that but there you go
I didn't live a life for ten years I
just thought about comedy but I also was
doing drugs and whatever you know mites
my goal was this to do you know a couple
sets a night and after that one set
that's when the party starts right and
it was ever there that's where you go
home with you know whatever you wake up
in the morning the same going nobody
knows about to the next day you know
it's weird it's a weird thing in the
beginning you know like how just you
live your life like a no minute a lot of
people can't live their life like nomads
they need structure but I always had
structure as a nomad mm-hmm that's the
thing if you're gonna be a nomad you
still have to have
structure mm-hmm I forced myself to have
structure well that was a nomad and then
when I first got to the store my first
structure was two phases it was cocaine
and comedy you did over here remember
them's my C and C's that's it and all I
thought about how to score I'll keep my
rent paid and how to do comedy everybody
that was my focus you know and it's so I
don't regret it at all
I had a great [ __ ] time if I had to
do it all over again or work and it
[ __ ] something I didn't want to do me
I take the same route all over again I
enjoyed sleeping in my car those three
months I enjoy sleeping on Ralphie's
floor like if I could do it again I'd do
it again right you know it was his comic
that he was one of the first time was to
have a CD out and he was horrible and
one night he gave the CD to Ralphie and
at night we used to have a running joke
everybody tired yep alone that comic CD
and we'd all fall asleep to it like
every night oh really
yeah we'd all fall asleep to the same
scene instead of somebody reading you a
bedtime story laughs let's see people
this right the bag Jesus but it isn't
like I still remember getting on stage
which suits on it that you wore suit Oh
cuz you still wear a suit only three
months you did that three or four months
I always got on stage with suits on for
months and lasted for months and out of
the four months I won on stage probably
let's say 16 times a month with the suit
on four times a week and I went bottom
five times a week with a pseudo mmm-hmm
there was something about a suit that
put a block on me and when they said
I'll never wear a suit again because I
saw Lenny Clarke wear a suit and Rodney
Dangerfield special he came out with a
vest right right so I said I would
emulate him or a suit like him
but it was so weird as soon as I stood
the suit off I started getting laughs
interesting once I got down to the level
of Who I am because you can't put a silk
hat on a pig and people read through
sooner well when I was younger at night
and I know this sounds so dumb but when
I used to wear high heels I would never
have a good set because if I had like
high heel in the day was like mini
skirts and high heels and it's just like
because it it didn't feel grounded felt
like you're out the [ __ ] you know I mean
like and and people wouldn't buy it and
I didn't feel and I think cuz I didn't
feel comfortable in it but as soon as I
didn't care then it got better you know
what I mean it's funny cuz you don't
know when you're starting out you know
how to go about it how to figure it out
I want a person to feel comfortable on
stage like when I see a woman with heels
on stage it's tough for anyhow is
staying there I feel it when I'm looking
at them I'm saying to myself I wonder
what she's got in her feet moving around
like that [ __ ] you pulled Madonna all
those [ __ ] have fallen one [ __ ]
time we've all fallen I would hate to
see a comic want to fall like that but I
couldn't imagine going yeah like to be
grounded also right I like sneak is up
on stage no flip-flops no nothing no
shorts jeans t-shirt no big patterns no
if you're up front you gotta wear a
collared shirt if you they MC right
Margaret Cho told me you're you always
have to wear one fucked-up thing that
stupid thing a scarf
yeah something Donna yeah you know it's
so weird I've had the same hairdo since
I was a kid like everything is the same
you're the same hairdo since you were a
kid yeah where's your hair always
greased back but before grease it just
went up in here right okay you know I
just called and everybody just go up in
the air from the humidity and then I
started putting grease in my hair when
I'm over there like Boulder or something
what's he admitted he was gonna like I
just had to calm it down so it's the
same [ __ ] hairdo but there's no
change this there's been no evolution
might do did you do a mullet did you
ever do a mullet all the time oh you did
a mullet I still have like a half a
month I may hate you guys like really I
go yeah leave the length just cut off
the bushes it's not my [ __ ] ears look
like Pina like they're [ __ ] targets
and we don't even wish in the back
[ __ ] [ __ ] targets some what are
you gonna do no I don't believe in that
whole dress-up calmly I want you to be
updating yourself when I see somebody
dressing up to do family man it kinda
bothers me a little bit there's some
people who doesn't bother me what John
Mulaney doesn't he know yeah I like but
he looks comfortable in it that looks
like what he would wear to grow sister I
like the tiny girl when she wears furs
and gloves onstage yes yeah I call that
[ __ ] she she's yeah some people are
meant to sell it
some people are faking the [ __ ] you know
and that's it once I see anything of
economics armor that fakes the funk yeah
I can't pay it that gentle that's really
hard to be who you are at that level I
don't know it's just weird you know it's
like one I don't know I don't only get
myself in a hole here no but you don't
even like prop comics I got right but
you don't see prop comics no more right
you know I know remember when that was a
thing it's crazy right see a lot of
musical comedy no yeah but sometimes
does he's still guitar comedy here and
there but not like it was beside Cyrus
Oldman yeah guitar anymore the one guy
that girls that do Esther ku sometimes
does that shoot I think she fired the
ukulele yeah sometimes ever great once
somewhere I haven't seen her do it in a
while though I haven't seen mr. cool
period I had it on Twitter the other day
she in town she's been around yeah yeah
she's so funny but I see you getting
spots I'm starting to get spots again at
the comedy sir well let's start from the
beginning of this really weird years ago
you came to me once said hey you said
that [ __ ] miserable told you that you
weren't gonna get spots at the store no
Sean that'd be named the Frenchman's
[ __ ] yeah because I had quit comedy for
a while then I went back and I had was
hanging out a little bit and I was like
hey so
you know do I come on Mondays and try to
get on friends and family well like how
do I go about this and he looked at me
and he was just like we don't book any
of the old guys here but it made me
laugh because it was like that's [ __ ]
bold [ __ ] I wasn't even a regular I was
a regular at the store but I wasn't
going to the store right he told me that
I was like this guy has gone [ __ ]
crazy you know why did you stop going to
the store I stopped going to the store
because if I stopped going to a store
because of a lot of reasons I got the
surgery on my neck and I took the fat
ball out and the fat ball boy soon as I
saw it looked like a ball I hate and
just you know and the Cubans are very
superstitious to call it Monday or it
was just a lot of reasons I had done my
tenure there right you have to know in
life when you I never want to be kicked
out I want to walk on my own two feet
yeah okay so yeah at that time I saw the
guard changing a little bit
Mitsy started getting old I had already
been there like I said since 97 man and
it was 2006
and I just noticed little things I heard
little sayings people would say things
to me about rogen in a negative way but
trying to be cute offhanded and Tommy
was one of the first people that ever
came up to me while Rogan was on tour
with Eddie Murphy's brother and John
Heffron and Tom Segura those guys Joe
was gone for a long period of time and I
was up down one Thursday night or
something and him another guy that
remained unnamed came up to me and
they're like where's your buddy tonight
my trying to like might give me you're
in high school like like was you or was
your butt buddy like bro you know he's
on tour and he goes I didn't take it you
know like they were like busting my
balls and they said just to let you know
when he comes back things gonna change
around here
he's not gonna be able to do 45 minutes
it's stuck I don't know forget the light
did my spot it got my car and I went
home at the time Terry they're working
on war so I wouldn't cause the beef Fred
of the family or nothing so I just went
home made a mental note but when I came
down from the drugs the next day I saw
it wasn't a mental no I saw that there
was a declaration of war in my [ __ ]
paranoid cocaine money and I had not
done anything about it if that was me 20
years earlier I would have banged both
their [ __ ] heads together but I was
so addicted to the coke and Mike my
brain was so gone at the time that I
didn't know what they were saying to me
you know they were still like they were
threatening me like in a cute way like
two buddies 20 years ago with a sidekick
one guy and hit the other guy in the
head with a bottle and just drove away
it's like my addiction calm me down like
I was like am I gonna do that I'm just
like no home but right then and there I
go you know what before I end up in jail
before this goes down I'm just gonna
stop going up there something I go first
of all how fortunate my that mitzi sure
picked me to be a regular that's number
one I'm Way ahead of ya and for the last
seven years she's been giving me spots
so if you start and what's the club I
like in Provence the comedy connection
it's a great little Club it seats 250
you walk in there I [ __ ] Sunday man
do the Open Mic spot and then you do the
open mic every night you put work in
after seven years that'll be your home
club and by that time you'll be a
co-headlining
the room and one day the owners gonna
come up the end goalie I really like you
I know that your father's ill I know
that you take care of your mom but for
this career to go anyway you got to get
out of Providence you got to move on
it's like a seven-year window that you
have at a club before you and the thing
is when you're at the Comedy Store
such a privilege to be there you know
it's a mindfuck in its own way because
it's you know where you're trying to
learn your your craft right and it's
such a it's such an amazing thing to be
there but if it's your home club at a
certain point you have to fly like what
you're saying and it's so weird the turn
of events because it happened right
around this time 11 years ago it
happened in 2007 so I had the surgery
that January and after that January boom
rogon gets to whatever this little drum
at the store I was a little upset things
weren't working out how they wore it at
that time but I did a big motion feature
and nothing happened but the truth of
the matter is my addiction was at an
all-time high like I was called nuts
like I wasn't even hanging out with the
people I was getting on with the law I
was way beyond their level I was doing
three grams a night 6:00 in the morning
Terry would be waking up and I'd be
going to bed type [ __ ] you know that
type [ __ ] and I had already known them
we had to get out of this store like I
have to go out of the store I remember
that dome the tour finish for Rogan and
one night at the store Rogan pumped me
up before him and when we got off I pull
them aside they go let's give this place
a break just something's gonna go down
down here and he goes no no I don't know
what you talking about how you know and
a couple weeks later it was when the
seed was planted for the called Carlos
Mencia oh really so the whole Carlos
Mencia seed was planted in December I
was already pulling back mm-hmm I had
already know what was going on but
something else happened that was
interesting Madeleine Martinez diet may
reverse it was yesterday 11 years so at
that time I was clean from coke for like
seven or eight days or more the exact
amount because I was shooting a movie I
booked the movie and the guy told me
that he knew I was a [ __ ] coke fiend
that if I was gonna take the movie
either stop doing blow because I was
gonna [ __ ] up the production
schedule so that's why I quit boom well
then I went up to the store a blow by
Jeff fobb Eze I said that proves it that
I don't need to be at the store no more
that's the proof right there I'm too old
this life already I've lived this life
already I know when I'm volatile right
and I know and I don't belong some and
that night I knew when I went home in
the car to the store I call it brogurt
again about five days later it was when
I got the call the seed getting planted
for the whole Carlos thing I I didn't
take the bite I didn't take the bite so
they had other people they deployed
other people to put blood into Jo in
January 2008 isn't Joanne off on Carlos
it was around that January after the
Super Bowl commercial hollows have a
Super Bowl commercial so the tension
started December now the new year people
calm down people have new resolutions
and [ __ ] now it's the Super Bowl and
who's got the third commercial on slate
Carlos Mencia
well guess what everybody saw that and
the hatred came to a boil and made me
feel weeks later than torture to know
I'm on stage at the Comedy Store and
then no week later Joe gets banned yeah
so I saw the heat coming I saw how they
were gonna twist it around I got the
first call to be the first [ __ ] Judas
but I wouldn't buy it I said no if
Carlos is on stage I don't give a [ __ ]
if somebody is on a stage I don't give a
[ __ ] who's on stage and Carlos walks in
Carlos gets the bump that person that
was how they called me they called me to
ask me my opinion on what I thought
about Carlos or Eddie Griffin walking
into the store and I said here's my rule
my rule is I'm a peon if I'm in the back
of the room if I'm on stage and I see
Paul Rodriguez Paul Mooney Richard Pryor
at that time the guy who died Larry
Sanders
what's his name Gary chef Gary Shandling
used to come in when I first got there
mo mandel what's his name mine with
Holly Mandel Eddie Griffin
Andrew Yaka Yaka that time Yakov had
jewelry was brother Arsenio Arsenio by
that time once addicted Wayans yes Damon
could bump and that was an understanding
so as soon as you saw them you were like
[ __ ] yes
like if you had 11:45 you saw Damon you
were [ __ ] and then if you saw Damon
with the ten brothers you were doomed
cuz that's it they were doing a variety
show you're doomed
your agent is their grandmother flew in
spots at 11:45 you have an audition to
10:00 and Damon Wayans are walking with
the whole family with older brother the
creator of In Living Color and the two
younger brothers and you would just sit
there and go oh my god I'm dead and one
night there was a kid that won on
Keenen Ivory Wayans was on stage the
store and Thomas Ward said why don't you
get off the stage
and you let some funny black dudes go up
and say it that way he said it in the
more rough way he was black he's allowed
to say it okay the words he was allowed
to say I'm in she banned them for 30
days
oh really yeah because Kenan was up on
stage and he was supposed to go up next
you know people's [ __ ] them after a
while you take the beam 1145 and getting
bumped five nights in a row yeah yeah
and your spots now at 12:30 to 8:00 and
you got a rock of coke in your pocket
bread in a hole in your pocket you got a
chick that's ready to suck dick but you
can leave you can leave you always have
the option to leave and be a [ __ ]
mutt or you could stay and learn
something going there get pissed off and
watch this guy and then watch him die
for 10 minutes and then watch him turn
the room around and you go why that's
why he's a [ __ ] star that's what the
brilliant thing was when you got bumped
I used to get bumped
all the time icicle on there early on a
Saturday and try to get that 8:45 spot
nobody would be there and I just be
ready to walk I've been Garry Shandling
would walk yep mother [ __ ]
well you gotta calm down [ __ ] there you
are at 11:30 and then dice would come in
and he'd do that
oh yeah at least now have you bumped you
only allowed to bump by 20 minutes oh
really
yeah I can't do they'd let you know
right off the bat
yeah there's a very strict rule now yeah
when you see that light you got two
minutes [ __ ] and yes so was Tommy
the one that was in charge when that
whole Carlos thing went in yes right
he was the one of the instigators and to
try to get another comic ahead it was
just a weird thing in it and it could
only happen at the county store at that
time it's such a [ __ ] weird thing to
call it but the talent coordinator was
such a weird name for these people
because all they did was put me at ease
you know I'm saying home it's he was
available they were fax Lewis back and
forth and it was an attempt the position
of talent coordinator could be a [ __ ]
blessing or it could be a curse Lee you
don't know what it is to get tortured
you don't know what it is to be the town
coordinator at the Comedy Store
when people tell you you lost weight
great they start giving you spots in
their rooms if they pay everybody else
$50 they give you 75
you know the talent coordinators
positions at the drop position if you're
a comedian yeah yeah it could eat you
alive
I saw it eat somebody alive I saw either
come up a bar and it can eat you alive
if you're not a comedian because you
still get that power right for sure
that's alright in that way maybe the
talent coordinator but then it's like
how do you wouldn't when you're in a
position whatever job you're doing where
someone could totally change your life
but then you kind of like that person
but you don't want to kiss ass that's
where I always get all [ __ ] up you
don't mean like how do I approach this
person should I just usually just
people be and then people think I'm not
friendly because I feel like everybody
wants to suck their dick why why should
I get on this - there's two rules yeah
there's two rules when it plain and
simple eh
be yourself be funny right yes yes if
you do those two rules yeah you got no
beef with nobody it's when you go out of
that thing
there's people they're not slick huh
they're not slick well wouldn't it be
obvious if like someone like I imagine
they're like it's like in the entourage
like if they're just like like let's see
how was the talent coordinator but then
they switch a lot so what if I got fired
in there suddenly your talent
coordinator and all those people are
kissing up to you like isn't it other
people who just switch from personal
person like brother
listen we were talking about him when I
went the province and Danny Kelly you
know I love you and I'll tell the story
I was Danny Kelly's room read what he
was I I and I've told this on the
podcast before there's two things I
observed early on to Josh wolf
development deal and the Danny Kelly
situation I was very fortunate
I knew it existed in the world I knew it
existed in the world I came from but I'm
a [ __ ] criminal I'm a criminal but I
didn't know it existed in the comedy
world and in the county world it's worse
than in the criminal world because in
the criminal world I know where you
stand I know you're dangerous I know
you're a [ __ ] thief I know you cut
your [ __ ] drugs
I'll only and I know you don't pay your
bills I know if you carry a knife with
these people you don't really know where
they stand
that's why Harvey dies like Harvey
Weinstein were created because you don't
know where the [ __ ] you staying with
these guys the power goes to a different
level you know Harvey one scene in the
beginning was a nice guy he would take a
look at you maybe you know I'm saying
towards the end if you read some of that
stuff it was just straight to the sucker
and [ __ ] me I'm saying I mean he just
got that powerful I'm sure every time
moving the little line you know me
looking in the mirror and going I'm
gonna meet Scarlett or whatever our name
is at lunch and she's gonna suck my dick
what like you have to be [ __ ] crazy
to be a guy like me and think that
Scarlett Johansson's gonna suck your
dick because he just invites you to
that's a reality right right cuz he just
invites you to a hotel yeah like you
think about how powerful he got in his
mind how the power just ran the [ __ ]
away with right so that's at every level
in Hollywood now we got Les Moonves now
we have these seasons these aren't bad
guys these are like guys that started
out like this these are guys that got a
powerful position and the tool and they
figured out they had a [ __ ] ace in
their pocket at all times okay and you
go in there with a dream you don't want
to go back to [ __ ] top peak of Kansas
has a loser at least you know saying so
there's just so many variables to this
now we break it down to comedy what
efforts got to the Comedy Store with
Scott day he was a serious guy and I was
serious for them zero kissed his ass
zero kissed his ass I asked him for
advice he was my friend and I respect
the hell out him and he's probably
listening to this podcast right now but
I hate he really was great at what he
did he listened to Mitzi and Emma Mitzi
put together great lineups and I thought
they came and they went and I saw what
the position did to some of the guys
some of the guys abused women some you
know they they whatever happened
happened you know whatever the [ __ ]
happened happen but that's such a weird
spot to have I was a dad I was Danny
Kelly's room and here I was busting my
hump [ __ ] ya know going on the road at
Rogen a little bit doing spots at the
store followed and Danny Kelly lived
here in LA yes and me and the stripper
broke up okay Danny Kelly from
Washington from Seattle yeah
I can't Danny Kelly and his girlfriend
broke up and Danny Kelly lived across
the street from rock'n'roll Ross okay
so it's that hotel right across the
street and
behind the printing places that were
Josh wolf left - no - more Flores
okay towards corsola this was in a
building that had with jacuzzi and a
pool so he had a one-bedroom so he gave
me the bedroom and he stayed in the
living room and I just slept on my
clothes and on a duffel bag duffel bag
was my pillow there was no sleep apnea
machine then there was nothing there was
a blanket I had a half a blanket but
there was a calendar on the wall and it
was his counter and I had been looking
at that calendar and when going how the
[ __ ] is he getting these gigs he just
wasn't getting gigs he was getting gigs
at the headliner yeah I mean you know
the Ventura Club before was this club
right there was a room in Orange County
and had her to give him he was a talent
coordinator at this school oh I see what
you're saying
Toby qalam you the funniest guy in the
world come on come on down and Danny was
a funny guy you know he's a great guy
right and then one day Mitzi found out
about some [ __ ] that was going down and
she fired I mean he walked into work but
his stuff was in the [ __ ] box hey
listen you're not even allowed to go
upstairs and he went home death
afternoon he was a little cracked he ate
dinner and he got a spot at the improv
in those days you know how hard it was
to get a spot the Monday night was the
hottest night in Hollywood it was a
freaky Monday and it was their version
of a black plate and from 8:00 to 840 it
was hot white acts with the tropical
8:40 beam Dave Attell or Pablo Francisco
and then after that just went black he
was getting spots there which is a huge
drag those days so he gets fired from
the [ __ ] comedy coordinators job on a
Monday he heads to the improv nobody
really knows he got five yet he goes on
stage he does his first joke and the
power goes out of the building the whole
building went down and he stayed up
there for a few minutes with a wider but
he knew I got it sent them all
we got home within two days uh-huh you
would see the slashes in the calendar
can't support oh right oh we're not
doing that gig anymore and I'm the man
though I lost three more gates today I
lost four more exciting I saw a decline
of a man that how creepy this town is
when they want something from me you
know so right there I learned my biggest
lesson that they always come dresses
whatever and they always come they're
wolves dressed in sheep's clothing I
mean he was getting games that people
were dreaming of like local gigs I'm
paying a thousand bucks in those days a
thousand bucks I'd clothes suck your
dick four thousand five thousand [ __ ]
bucks are you crazy
right Wow Wow
that's a lie I think the biggest lesson
though like when you're starting out is
you have to have your fingers in a
couple different bowls don't you think
you can't like I see I've seen a lot in
my time and comedy were people who have
stuck only with one person and have
never ventured out but that sometimes
it's not good to either you know what I
mean we venture out just like you know
like they'll only do gigs in one club or
they'll only you know II mean they won't
hang out with different types of comics
they only hang out with their group
because you know people always go in
their group right there's you rogon
group right there's like chick comedy
group there's you know all sorts of
different groups and but the best thing
that I have been happy about in my
career is I've been able to hop around
in a lot of different groups because I
think it's important cuz it makes you
grow like I go it 27 years you know I'm
friends a lot of comics I see him I give
him a big hug I'm happy for the success
we're still in this [ __ ] thing you
know a fortunate does all that stuff but
there's also the the thing like I was
telling you at the house before what I
know it's good for me you know after I
shot the Netflix special I saw 10
million holes in my game I real
it's the weirdest thing you're saying
after you shot it but hadn't seen the
finished product before I sold for this
price yeah I knew I had if it had holes
in my head
and I thought about it for a week and I
read some of my writings I'll have
written at night and I figured out where
the trigger was see because I write
instead of paying for a [ __ ]
psychiatrist I just write on this paper
I read it back weeks later okay I just
had fear fear was starting to come back
in my wife fear going to the store
not for your flower people not that
stuff just fear mm-hmm I got lazy I'd
rather go to this club or this club of
this club you're sit in the back and you
ask yourself what the [ __ ] am I doing
here I could be at the Comedy Store
I'm sitting here with the [ __ ] bring
a show or this [ __ ] and that's where I
ventured out and I didn't like the
results so for me to be the animal that
I need to be I need to be in the
original room once or twice a week as a
tune-up and then the main room like once
or twice a week like this we got the
five spots that's my weekly goal if I
don't go on the run it's like pop to
Tuesday to Thursday and maybe one on
Saturday
can I ask you when you shot your Netflix
one cuz I know you had said to me that
you weren't that happy with it right
after you shot it what were that what
were the three top holes that you caused
when you were telling me that I couldn't
even believe it because I just know you
as a performer what did you feel like
were the holes the holes were hole
number one
I stuck I depended too much on the
material you never depend on your
material you need to pay your material
depends on you that was the first
[ __ ] hole of my game
you never depends on your material your
material depends on you and then if you
see an opening you attack it I was
playing my game to say I'm an attacker I
have to attack I have to agitate and
then go in for the kill if not I'm not
rather you I forgot all those skills and
those are the skills you pick up at the
[ __ ] Comedy Store when you follow up
all morning at 12:45 I always tell
comics the biggest gift is when you show
up you have to abandon your material you
just wrote eight minutes on the most
brilliant documentary you see but the
guy in front is doing that same
documentary okay you gotta there's
nothing like bailing on your material
and finding the strength that you have
sometimes you don't have to believe in
our material that much we have a super
[ __ ] strengths that we forget to use
but the original room is such a
different animal like I've been doing a
lot of late-night spots and and when you
go up how many people in the room it's
all it all varies it can be like 20 or
it can be you know 40 it's mostly
they're scattered yes so that's a good
different type of exact yeah yeah that's
a different type of attack because you
got to attack at the two o'clock at 12
o'clock right at 10 o'clock so you got
to keep attacking and taking little
steps and then sometimes you have to
actually go from 2 o'clock to ten
o'clock it's a tremendous right body
movement and some of those people have
been there since the beginning and then
you know they've heard every variation
of every you know person ever and but
then and that goes in and out like I was
there for Halloween and I felt like I
lived three different lifetimes waiting
for my small that's like I had three
nights and one at the company store on
Halloween and I went up like 115 you
know and but it's the you can you're
with the original room you can never
plan what you're gonna do you can never
plan out what you're gonna do you go
that's why yeah if I ever get any other
type of special again six weeks yeah I'm
just doing
four lights of midnight Wow
four nights put me up at midnight well
if you really like Joey Diaz you gonna
hang out we should all go hang out
tonight Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
have you watched your whole special no
no no have you watched any of it a
couple of minutes
it's really good Joey I'm too
embarrassed no so I just turn yes I
don't want to watch it because not yet
yet I'll be ready for it eventually I'll
watch it I'm not ready for it yet let
their toll
you know do you think you were
projecting a lot of negativity on it
because you were in a vulnerable space
when you shot it I said I recently did a
gig at the Writers Guild and like Bill
Brewer was on it Iida rodriguez was on
like all these comics were on it and I
was so nervous because it was in front
of all the writers at the Writers Guild
and I was second one on I had to follow
yang what's that gentlemen's day and
crazy rich Asians Oh yang anyway
sorry I can't remember his name but I
was so nervous and I went up and I did
my thing but I was a little bit too
precious but I did solid I did solid but
it's when you're it's when you are so
afraid to play a little bit you know to
me because you're just like I just I
don't want to [ __ ] this up because yeah
I think you know because everybody's
here and you know and you get so
precious with it that I was totally
beating myself up when as I got off the
stage but in reality had a good set you
know do you think you were projecting a
lot because you were being too
protective of of staying in order of
your material and trying to be too
organized with it I could calm me so
[ __ ] 15 years before anybody knows and
then the time the time I pick up a
little [ __ ] gift but this was
different this jump was different just
now depends I have a wife and a child
that needs seed so that Richard Pryor
Lenny Bruce aspect of my comedy that I
really enjoyed what's going on is it
working is it tape yeah so what that
hold Lenny Bruce Richard Pryor thing
left from my mind and that Kennison
think that dice thing because now I have
audiences that pay for babysitters they
pay the park they pay for a ticket they
pay for two drinks and they come see me
I do not want to take a chance and for
that chance to go down a foxhole it
doesn't work so I started playing my
cards to stop guess where I was doing
that at Howard also at the comedy store
because I know that people come from
overseas and they go to the comedy store
and they check in and they want to see
different family every Tuesday night so
I let my mind take off that's what they
ins I the anxiety attacks coming from
they were coming from within because I
was starting to get sick by the time I
passed the generalist or all the way
down a little K and I'm already getting
sick no I know we one time we're driving
and you are getting very nauseous and
dizzy and as we're going to the comedy
star I was going out of my comfort zone
even I didn't want to go out of anymore
I can't be that guy no more that crazy
guy in the original but that crazy and
the original was the one that said
things that you know we all got off
stages and what the [ __ ] just happened
like that was not scripted like this is
what happens when you have to follow
Paul Mooney and there's 16 people in
that and you better [ __ ] grab you
don't have time to [ __ ] around if not
you're gonna bomb it's gonna be a long
night and you're just gonna go up there
and learn the bomb every night in front
of 16 people you're gonna learn how to
burn them so the only one way to
overcome
16 to 20 people is by kicking up the
energy a notch kick them up the energy
in a summation heartbeat a little
it takes you to different places may she
work a little bit more racist oh yeah
you know I go off and it's not see it's
not racist to me but it's racist now and
now you can't say it if I said chick or
chant the Hindu now they just feel free
like last night I called the guy that
took the kid down to the cave a [ __ ]
when they came back I'm saying like they
came back like I'm trying [ __ ] but I
don't give a [ __ ] what are you gonna do
leave there and write a blog about me
saying something that ship sail yeah
what's the purpose of that to say that
the purpose is urine that's who you are
I'm on a street corner and 78th Street
and Kennedy Boulevard and we're [ __ ]
four or five guys and they checked and
we're talking [ __ ] about last night and
the way to describe that guy is by
saying the [ __ ] Hindu we went opening
that three little lottery tickets from
the Hindu and you know it was a
different world it was the world of
racism and everything took everything so
[ __ ] literal you know I was telling a
story and an Arab print 50 years ago
first was take stolen cars to Joe the
Arab up and [ __ ] Maya that's the
first guy I knew that was Arabia that's
when we just want a tool everybody loves
an Arab right yeah you didn't give a
[ __ ] if they smell like hummus yeah you
didn't give a [ __ ] now they're
everywhere so that special no more you
back in the day that don't mean you're
racist listen my best friend for three
years was a guy named Mohammed's a beep
we started out he was my tutor at the
University of Colorado for economics
best friends and he wore the sandals he
had the guard bomb the whole [ __ ]
thing uh-huh
I blow against them I love them to death
he I gave up a story thermos yeah it's
after you got out of yeah okay disaster
I didn't have nothing against somebody I
always topping one of my best best
friend in the world I'm never
forgettable my Harmons a beat
I snore coming to my house I still come
to comedy shows in the beginning oh
really
the very beginning and being impressed
Lee coming because he was like a ladies
man my little white chick team is
married back in it and in Deauville
but his mom comes to come back and he's
like I'm not coming back
I'm getting my dick sucked yoga teacher
this sucking dick like it's [ __ ] the
yum-yum steak yeah cuz he taught like
yoga part time yeah baby bang a white
chick I knew more about your vehicle's
power trio them he would lift the accent
up a little bit the Arabian accent [ __ ]
is crazy over this [ __ ] I'm sharing
Colorado I'm sure ya [ __ ] woods would
be nice guy so yeah it's not the same
racist things is that you're talking
from the heart and you're saying
different I don't listen I don't believe
in saying I don't believe I'm winning
the war to lose the battle I'm not one
of those guys comedy those [ __ ] yeah
they're funny on a Monday night when it
comes time to get a paycheck you're not
gonna get a paycheck if you win the war
lose the battle that's it you said
something cool oh my god you're so
valiant but look at the people what'd
you do you just [ __ ] them up you're
gonna have you in an abortion joke
you're gonna kick the fetus of an
aborted baby all those things I don't
want to hear that stupid fair enough
Joey Diaz fair enough that and I'm gonna
just bring it back because whatever but
I thought that that's what I liked about
your special is I thought it was
challenging I thought was hilarious and
I thought at the end joy I [ __ ]
cheered up because I thought you really
showed who you were in an honest way and
it was funny and it was heartwarming and
it was challenging all in one it was
really fantastic really imagine living
your life right now when you first got
married to the GI
Olivia had kids with him and if you were
yearned to be a pounds heavier you would
miss wearing sandals you've got diabetes
too quick with Crohn's and God knows
what else right look you haven't yet
because you didn't do what you wanted to
do Oh every time I because when you were
saying earlier at dinner about when you
would get dizzy driving over the hill to
go to the comedy store and I was saying
cuz I do have Crohn's disease and I was
saying yeah every time I get sick it's
when I'm doing something that that I'm
not listening to myself and I'm just
bullshitting and I mean like I'm
participating in something that my body
is literally like and no and I think
everybody has that part for some people
it's a bad back you know me for some
people it's you know nay mean I felt
that when I shot to see so special it
was good but I didn't let loose I held
back because I didn't want to give them
what they wanted from me but guess what
Led Zeppelin never goes up there and
plays the Rolling Stones okay the
pretenders never go up there and play
Pat Benatar the pretenders always a
pretenders and the Rolling Stones I'm
not I'm not comparing myself to that I'm
just making a metaphor that I love doing
comedy and I love Redd Foxx and I love
Richard Pryor and I love the style of
comedy I do it's Who I am there's nobody
that could talk about eating [ __ ] and
fingers up your [ __ ] and say you want
me to tell you something a woman told me
in Philadelphia you talk about that
stuff it's kind of dirty but it's kind
of erotic it turns you on in the way one
woman out of all of them that have seen
it so far
but no no I like that type of land which
I want to [ __ ] be dirty I want the
[ __ ] that bothers me to go up there is a
[ __ ] what they think and that's what
that's it like once I have all that
safety another way but you know what man
my family owe 8 I've been doing this for
27 years
stop eating right it I'd rather be Who I
am on stage than be who you want me to
be and feed my family I'd rather be able
to [ __ ] I am taking a lower paycheck and
feed my family right and [ __ ] play
your [ __ ] songs and do [ __ ] rumps
and whatever the [ __ ] it is that you
like right you know and if you walk out
you walk out but there's no reason why
you should walk out because is YouTube
there's YouTube YouTube any comments not
before you buy it thinking you don't
listen to your friends and be a sheep
and say okay I'll go with you hold on
one second let me go on YouTube this
[ __ ] ain't my cup of tea he's up
there talking about kidnapping to do
some kidnaps so that's the edge we get
now everybody who pays for a ticket is
in yeah yeah so my main concern was
letting down right I don't want to let
people know so you have to work on it
you have to really give them what they
want alright you know what man people
just want a real experience Joey and
that's what you're offering that's what
you are we Shou is uh we used to date
Amy Schumer good-looking guy oh yeah
very good writer
Anthony definitely just something I wish
I could write like ant and I wish I
could write like the guy that created
Chappelle a day when I wish I could
write like John Mulaney but the fact is
I can't that's just a way in is that if
I did write like them and what up on
stage that did what they did I would
just be I would just be it's a slow
suicide you are a good writer for your
own way and that's that you have your
own thing and that's the most important
thing everyone can learn the trick on
how to write a joke you can take a class
like I did you can learn that trick but
you have to be yourself
I want to write a joke tell them my
statement knock them off balance a
little bit and then explain to them from
a vine in my life why I made that
statement and that's what you did in the
special as you said all that stuff and
then
at the end you spoke about your mother
but it the way it happened and I'm not
kissing your ass because I don't give a
[ __ ] but whoa you but but the way when
you did that is you explain to people
this is by just doing that story this is
who I am this is my experience you know
I mean you give yourself permission to
talk that way because you it's real you
know what I mean and it's accessible to
people you're more accessible to a
certain crowd of people then Mulaney is
I never watch a comedy special I watched
yours I'll watch my friends here and
there but to go through one when you're
just flipping channels but I did land on
mulaney's and I was like [ __ ] just
blown over all the way but that's his
that's his different kind of skill
that's his thing your thing is just as
valuable it's just different
you know and I mean thank God if we were
all like ya know everyone would [ __ ]
comedy wouldn't sell any tickets uh are
you adjusting how you do your sets at
all because even leading up to that you
would do some of the same bits but your
set is different every time you do it
you don't really stick to too much of a
set list no especially at the Comedy
Store The Comedy Store she wanted from
the beginning for it to be a creative
place he's gonna be favoring over the
door a little bit Felice I'm sorry to
bother she wanted that place to be a
workout room somewhere had a few
conversations of people and again this
is the problem that you let different
things get into your mind and it affects
you different ways I got into different
conversations of people and they would
say to me well the Commodores phenomenal
but I have no place to go work out at
all
why not because I got a follow wrong way
and I can't try five minutes in the
material when I'm following Ron White
Chris D'Elia Joe Rogan
what's the Amy Wong Ali walk I can't I
can't try new material because I'm gonna
look that bad and then I figure that
whoa back to Mitzi shore 101 back to the
book the original room and the belly
room where creative resource rooms the
main room was way you were polished and
where she puts you up on the weekend but
the purpose of the original was for
everybody to be more creative let
yourself go to pull the darkness out of
you
when you get really the people leave the
store have you talked to people who left
the store now I didn't like that place
whatever it's because it does something
to you it goes deeper into your soul it
makes you draw out of your soul and
there's people I can't handle that
that's why I'm only in problem I'm not
gonna improv right well the Impala is a
different type of comic over the years I
learned the more I put my soul into my
set the more I didn't really matter what
I said as long as they knew where my
heart stood as new as long as they knew
the compass to where my heart stood I
could say all those racial slurs and
talk about eating [ __ ] because they
know where your heart is and that's the
most important thing than get out that
takes years that takes storytelling yeah
it takes some time to take this you
become a comedian one day and then I
invite you to do a storytelling is
showing you either bag that next the
first three times this it's a different
animal me but once you get the
storytelling really strong now you have
this whole thing now now your comedy bit
has a beginning a middle and an ending
in fact you could even write what is the
message of this joke mm-hmm and the joke
will start flowing out more alive and
I'll come with a story are you tiring
luck whatever the [ __ ] you that's the
hardest part is learning your story and
when you're doing comedy is being able
to have a great story and deliver jokes
I think that's the hardest part is the
story sometimes the let's the last piece
that you learn it's so weird I went for
the Lord I was talking to Eddie Brown
once and he was telling me when he was
before you started getting really good
even ago for ankle locks and that's like
easy pickings in Brazil when you go for
ankle locks they throw shoes at yoga mat
because it means that you're gonna feel
a little hanging tree you know and my
first 18 months economy I gotta be
honest with ya it was basically one line
that was written and the next eight
minutes were improvised you know because
I had to be in front of the same
audience
every Tuesday Felicia and they were all
on the same type of much stay with only
coming on Tuesday nights because it was
a 15 night dollar state plus they got a
county ticket the stakes were usual a 25
bucks to the broker and Boulder and
Denver oh really
they had four of them uh-huh romantic
place great concept till this day I give
them I send them my love and I send a
big shout out for them to helping me in
my career in the beginning especially
the one in Boulder I forget what the
managers were and the waitresses I know
some of their names but that was my
developmental spot for a year and a half
I went there every Tuesday I would stay
up every Monday night sometimes I do
blow some nights I'd stay up on for your
open mic this you know and I would write
the jokes for Tuesday at at boulders
paper Oh take the bold daily camera for
the whole week and I would take the
front page or some write jokes topical
jokes because this is pre-internet this
is great I remember you having like
getting a USA Today and they used to
have this one section where it'd be all
the little dumbass stories from each
state in the USA today and so I would go
to that because I'd have some like
Florida man story like back in the day
but they would do from each state like a
little blurb of weird crying yes so for
my first 18 months in comedy I just used
material from the paper to write jokes
because they were all boulder locals so
it wasn't like I didn't have to be
[ __ ] Johnnie genius I would just
write local matter
go up there and riff and improvise and I
got really good at that yeah your that's
your session I went to New York and find
out that everybody in improvise in New
York ten people got on stage how you
guys doing tonight
so what do you do for a living you're a
construction guy you like building and
they just won something yes for sure cuz
I remember I was a regular at The Comedy
Store till about I think I moved to New
York in like 94 and I was all like hey
my name is Felicia Burrell and I go to
New York right and and I go into the
club I think was comics the comic strip
and then I was like hey and they were
like what the [ __ ] is this then I was
all like wow this isn't gonna work here
so there it was like hey everybody
hasn't had that and for me even though I
had the privilege of being at the Comedy
Store for such like eight or nine years
at the beginning to me going to New York
is is when it switched for me because
the Comedy Store was like my home club
it's a club I started and really and so
to go to New York it broke all my bad
habits that I had learned at The Comedy
Store it was tremendous tremendous what
had happened did you have from the
comedy stuff well I'm just not grow not
because I came at the comedy store and I
was so young I was like little Felicia
at the Comedy Store like everyone's
little pet that they would you know rub
the top of my head you know what I mean
and I didn't even though it's really
filthy I didn't I didn't stretch who I
was I wasn't curious about anything and
moving to New York made me have to kind
of face the person I really want to be
you know what I mean I know that sounds
crazy but at that time I had done
playboy so I was just like shedding like
layers of me because it was like you
know I don't want to wear high heels and
suck my gut in and wear a push-up bra to
tell [ __ ] jokes anymore you know so I
did playboy let's make that go away you
know what I mean and it was like just
peeling layers like an onion you know
you could playboy did you change your
attire onstage now I went through like
probably like a year of around playboy
where I dressed up a little bit more
because I would did the Playboy and they
kind of sent me
if you a little bit then but but then
when I moved to New York that's when it
really changed it it really changed you
know and it was also a whole new bunch
of comics you know at that time like at
El and all those you know Geraldo all
those people you know and so it was just
a nice
you know because you can get stuck in a
club it's like you being at The Comedy
Store and deciding to leave right when
the whole Robin thing happened
you just get to where you know you got
to move out of the house you know what I
mean it's like you're 19 living at home
so you got to move out of house for a
little while you know what I mean you
know I think the special came out Monday
night at midnight and I did rogen that
afternoon and I was kind of Numb about
it I didn't know what the response would
be or what happened I didn't really care
I just wanted Monday to be over with and
I got up Tuesday morning and helping up
the computer and I had 12 messages on
the [ __ ] on Facebook and I probably
have like an 11 on Twitter and the whole
Twitter page is covered and I got up and
I got some coffee
you know I shook it off a little bit I
got some coffee and then after I drink
my coffee I wait like 10 minutes so I do
my first bong hit I took a little [ __ ] I
think everything globalizes I wash my
hands and sometimes sometimes I got a
little pile of coffee
and I know I make another cup of coffee
and I drink half of it it's 7:15 in the
morning I went back to Facebook and it
was a message on that one girl I'd grown
up with then we were really tight
growing up with her boyfriend was a
Marine I had him one time me and her
robbed a local pool place an actor [ __ ]
over the fence cuz I couldn't jump
fences so I'm gonna pushing her over the
fence and the whole thing she's a
dynamite chick and she hit me up and she
was like you know
to see to open up Netflix and to see you
administer world to me your mother must
be really happy and proudly when I'm
when I turned it off and I did what I
was doing and I walked into the kitchen
and what came to me was leaving Boulder
leaving Boulder either June 1st or July
1st of 95 leaving my daughter Jacqueline
leaving a bad relationship this
addiction this rocky apartment that I
had I kept it I paid rent for three
months cuz I figured I was just gonna
Seattle for a month and come back but I
knew in my heart that if I went and left
that I had to go for it like I had to go
for it I couldn't come back to Boulder
beat up 20 years later and say I went I
gave it a try but it didn't work out
at that moment it hit me what necklace
was and I walked into my kitchen and my
brother frigerator I had a mini heart
attack I just flipped over put my hands
on the counter and just it was like 22
years of Tears
it was the final load off my shoulder of
pain like it was it Terry came and asked
what was going on I said I was thinking
about something and then later on after
school I told her the truth I said that
little mini heart attack because I can't
believe that I made that decision when I
was driving on too long month I had a
catch 272 a long month or whatever 11
were going if I do this I have to do
something with my life I just can't
leave both I'm leaving a great little
rocky apartment I have a job like a
probably makes 60 70 grand a year
I work half the yet deliver Chinese
friggin cocaine and cheap I get weed
cheap I had everything I wanted to but I
got out of my comfort zone it was so
weird how this all goes back to going
out of your comfort zone to become a
good comic and that's what was killing
me at the store and anxiety now I do 90
down Laurel Canyon
the [ __ ] air sickness that little
[ __ ] sickness I was getting right has
disappeared
good cuz I was [ __ ] annoying yeah but
now to you you know this guy tells you
to go to [ __ ] away I remember talking to
you the next day a translator it was the
best thing he could have ever done Joey
in hindsight you do but it made me laugh
too cuz it's like look at this
[ __ ] but then it was the best
thing that he could have ever done
because the truth of the matter is I
should have go away and Andrey learned
my craft and but you know I was a
different person to than when I was in
my 20s you know so I couldn't even do
the material that I had done in my 20s I
had to relearn how to do everything and
it was the perfect that he said the
perfect thing to me that [ __ ]
but he said the perfect thing to me then
you started hanging out the story so I
seen you down you started a podcast or
buyers club the buyers club with Jessica
Wellington there on Monday family [ __ ]
and then one day you started calling for
spots do you know Alex oh god he was in
uh he he's curly redheaded guy I'm sorry
I can't remember his last name but he's
a regular but he was hanging down there
and I was like you know sometimes I do
the belly room for tammyjo and he was
like well your names on the wall don't
you call him for spots I was like yeah
it doesn't work that way and they told
me I was too old he said who told you
I'm like wool Tommy and he's like [ __ ]
that doesn't so different people know
just call in just [ __ ] don't be an
[ __ ] just call in Alex Hooper is his
name he's a really great guy and so I
just started calling in and I didn't get
anything and then I'd get a little
discouraged and Jessica's like no just
[ __ ] call in but it was more about
just hanging around and we started our
podcast we'd sneak up into the belly
room during the day and so we did about
15 weeks of sneaking around and then
they're like you guys can come down now
to the podcast me or whatever and so
it's been a really fun little thing to
do and she's the first person that I've
done a podcast since you or I'm like
this totally fits you know natural you
yeah it's natural yes
girl she's she's awesome karma Morales
karma Morales [ __ ] making moves yeah
yeah and Jessica's was the first girl
door guy at the Comedy Store ever and
and not for none
Jessica [ __ ] you up like I wouldn't
raise my hand no [ __ ] Jupiter on Long
Beach because you got no insurance
I was surprised oh she's like you
wouldn't do a podcast I was like you're
talking to me okay that was so crazy and
like 2009 before I married Carrie I went
for a Santeria read you know and he was
talking we know you know you come into
an age where you have to be like a
leader and what you do know what the
[ __ ] leader
what am i part of the gang you know and
it hit me one day that I'm an older guy
and the support of the young guy is
especially at the store or any comic has
to be overwhelming when I see the young
guys doing their thing like last night I
saw the girl that just got married to go
up after me one of the dog girls she
married a dog guy he's real pretty girl
they're both like the best-looking
couple in America
oh she bartend - sometimes I think so
yeah she's really beautiful yeah and
then you know she gave me a big hug it's
weird to see like Hayes Hayes astray
know the war Indian kid we're thinking
I'm taking him to Brad to open up for me
as a door guy at the store you know
there's a system right there's a system
people think that is a system you know I
see these guys at the store fighting in
and out every night for what I don't
know what the [ __ ] they pay him if
they're comics from time to time I got
an opening I think I'm on the road why
not give him a shot at what it's like I
can't take him every week but just to
show on the same way Jimmy Shuba took me
that time to Jacksonville the same way
that guy took me that time when I needed
it you know for three days even going
knock the socks off you never called me
again but at least he brought me you
know it's a
continuing fun on that climber you know
I took Lena Boston you know he wasn't
ready for a world with either but I
didn't give a [ __ ] I threw him up head
for the Wolves and he handled it now
it's on how was that how was that that
was great it was awesome and Mondays at
the fourth wall for the eighteen people
looking at him like he's you know nine
nine people you committed a felony you
know that's at this [ __ ] journey he's
all about
I'm happy when I saw you Nate last
Tuesday or two Tuesday's ago I had to do
that that's the night that Jimmy and
Harry got into the fistfight in the
living room and the Harry's nail got
stuck in them easier
oh so I couldn't go down to the store
that was on the greatest lineups I know
I was so proud of you I was like this is
the sickest lineup it was a great night
out and I was the last one on the line
white the we are bobbing alley I think
David Spade it's crazy it was just crazy
and you were on that one yeah now when
you're on that one what time does that
mean you go up its can vary it can vary
like sometimes it's one sometimes it's
1:30 but you know so what I'm not
complaining them your time or do they
just let you run if there's people there
they I think I've seen mother [ __ ]
comically wait all day to go up at 1:56
oh I know that's really Joey yeah no
we're coming to the stage Lisa I yet you
run up that 156 in the morning yeah and
there's nine people and there you are
thinking you're at the [ __ ] God in
front of 18,000 people and there's three
guys wanting to go on after you but they
two o'clock they can't get liquor yeah
yeah so sometimes the management goes
now but there's 60 people in there and
you're rocking and rolling no keep it
open
don't keep it open but that's a great
feeling yeah when somebody says you want
to do five and close it out you're like
[ __ ] yeah and you go up there for
eight people so one-third these when you
go up sometimes sometimes yeah you know
it's been that what
was listening when you were talking all
about having nerves and getting dizzy
coming over the hill and and the
nervousness you felt after you did your
Netflix thing because I obviously on a
tiny level but being back at the store
and doing those one o'clock 1:30 spots
you know I feel like I'm not letting
loose enough like how you were saying
about letting loose and being yourself
you were too confined in your own
material and I feel like maybe I need to
do it a couple times to get the feel of
the room again you know do you ever feel
like that if you're away from the
original room on the road or whatever
and you come back does it take a while
to find the rhythm of the room again yes
and no Tuesday night leave was damn I
had a rough night Tuesday in the
original home I had a men's of Malta
night last night and Tuesday night I did
really well the original room has a
rhythm and the rhythm is you gotta be a
[ __ ] happen that's the only way I
survive in the original room now I know
exactly the buttons I have to press how
high my voice has to be how there's just
so many little things but if I work on
all those little things in the original
I know that when I go on the road I'll
keep that pace up that's why I like that
pace I'll keep that pace up
I'll take chances if it doesn't work I
got the coverage for you [ __ ] right
don't worry about it but I'm gonna take
this [ __ ] little time out for myself
last landing written in the main room I
spoke about something that I never spoke
about before in a man front of 400
people I didn't give a [ __ ] in the main
room right so it's wherever I want to
take the conversation now there's no
more set way that there's a set list but
there really isn't right there's a set
list but there isn't it's an invisible
line and I think I work better under
those lines you know so it works for me
I see what it does when I'm on the road
and I'm really happy I'm really happy
that I'm seeing the teachings of Mitzi
shore everybody took something
place I don't know while people listen
to the podcast and say what are you guys
gonna shut up with this [ __ ] because
this is our bloodline and you guys are
in the workforce and you guys have the
same guidelines and stuff it's just in
different terms we're all doing the same
[ __ ] just trying to be better people
you know exactly exactly that's it so
how many times do we put another podcast
um what we're doing it once a week now
but we're starting to tape twice a week
so and we're starting to do a live show
with it so you do it the Icehouse we've
been doing that at the Ice House we're
hoping to do it at The Comedy Store too
so we'd have a some of our comedy
friends come on and we ask them to tell
two stories one is the truth and when
it's lied Lee's done it and and then we
try to figure out which one is a lie and
some of the stories are so [ __ ]
hilarious Lee stupid some people but
it's been a lot of fun and we're going
to Portland
we're gonna go to Portland the weekend
after Thanksgiving through the summer
first yes that'll be good I'm happy you
made time for me I'm happy thank you for
having me making things happen I'm happy
that you're part of the comedy sister I
know tell me what's the best feeling as
a comic is driving into the parking lot
at the Comedy Store at 9 o'clock at
night right yeah and you know what it's
really weird that we still have the
blessing to do it 20 years later I know
I feel very fortunate every time I look
like I said it's so weird how your
contrast I'm looking at things changes
the outlook if you look at something
like it's gonna suck it's gonna suck
yeah but if you really look at some
bloopers just perspective um when I
think about the comedy still not
especially we saw them go on the road I
have a wife I have a kid and they great
and I love did that do you know what
I'll get the [ __ ] out and my wife wants
me to [ __ ] okay this night I could tell
my wife wants to watch whatever [ __ ]
TV with English accents [ __ ] limey TV
the drinking pee I don't know what the
[ __ ] this saying so I could tell her she
wants me out of the [ __ ] savages
English no I [ __ ] love you
[ __ ] anyway
well if you're in the neighborhood you
want to check out Felicia's at the store
now averaging three spots a week like a
[ __ ] everyone stays out of town
yeah I'll see you guys we'll see her
with me up in Portland I think it's
November 28th to December first
assumption like that go to helium
dot-com and check out tickets right now
alright alright don't forget I'm n
Gotham's this weekend but it's sold out
I'm also November 21st I think I'm at
The Improv in Irvine and there's a few
tickets left for that too thank you guys
for [ __ ] always having my back thank
you for watching this special but before
we end this I gotta talk about a few
things alright listen a lot of things
happen when your [ __ ]
when you wipe it yeah you wipe it but
you leave a lot of residue and that
residue develops and pretty soon you're
walking around with a cane you don't
need the aggravation that's what Russia
dot-com comes in it's a port of a day
you would store yourself it takes less
than 10 minutes and you wash your
[ __ ] [ __ ] with nice water fresh a
lot [ __ ] fresco you understand me
you don't want them to cut down trees
this is the way to start by getting a
portable bidet all right they start as
low as $69 what's way and you imagine
showing up in a girl's house you want to
get your pipe sucked and your [ __ ]
smiles you don't need the decoration and
listen alright I believe in a shower
sometimes you don't have time to take a
shower
you always have time at a time to take a
Porto Rican shower that's when you put
them at Dan you dip your dick in there
your ball sack and you do your muffler
you wipe it down with a [ __ ] skin
then at least that area is [ __ ] clean
and in case you bump into a victim
that's what Richie does for you right
they still why [ __ ] have a [ __ ]
muffler if it's not gonna be clean
do yourself a favor go to tissue calm
right now and log in and log in the word
muffler MF M u FF l ER and get 10% off
your [ __ ] portable bidet and
like I said he'll please ask for three
years and
still working in my [ __ ] bathroom
it's tip-top Magoo nothing's happened
and I believe in the product that's why
they're back number two listen sometimes
you're looking at the mirror you like I
don't look Irish what do I do Joey I
don't look Irish women I do listen I
don't know what you're gonna do so I'll
tell you what you should start with
23andme 23andme is a personal genetic
service that helps you understand what
your DNA can tell you about you and your
family's story as your loved ones get
together this Thanksgiving you discover
more by a genetic connections that you
share you inherit your what may be your
big [ __ ] is maybe you're an having
your ears from your uncle or your mom
and your stepdad or your dad how much is
your DNA compared to your brother your
sisters this is all this is all
important 23andme ancestry service
allows you to see how your DNA breaks
out across 150 plus regions worldwide
worldwide trace parts of the ancestry to
a specific group or individual from a
thousand plus years ago and discover how
much Neanderthal DNA you inherited all
this right now you get a composition
report you can explore where your DNA is
from out of 150 regions worldwide with
claim 3 and me could also get an
overview the diverse group of people who
share your DNA find other 23andme
customers who share your DNA and
ancestors explore matches that range
from close family the distant relatives
to make new connections you can always
choose to hop in or out of this tool
where 23andme you share and compare tool
you can explore genetic similarities and
differences between you and your
relatives you can share reports with
family and friends even if they're not
customers so what I'm going to do for
you is this now through Thanksgiving as
a church soldier you're gonna do
yourself a little favor and get a
23andme ancestry service kit for only
$49 and you get to me they used to be
$99 alone that's 50% off the regular
price that's 99 for two of them this
holiday
order your 23andme ancestry service kit
at 23andme comm slash Church sh you are
that's 23andme dot-com / Church I did it
I found that I'm African Chinese Russian
Jewish I got everything
that's why they call me mad flavor going
to 23andme calm right now / Church and
get your ancestry service kit for $49
when you buy two or more kits
all right listen you're looking for a
good individual for your job for your
business you got you got an 8-man
business whatever but you know what you
also don't have time to be messing
around with the resumes and services
that send you the wrong things
you know what's smart I'll tell you what
job sites are overwhelm you with tons of
the wrong resumes but you know what is
smart zip recruited dot-com / Church
unlike other job sites
zip recruiter doesn't wait for
candidates to find you the zip recruiter
finds them before you it's a powerful
matching technology that scans through
thousands of resumes identifies people
with the right skills education and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply you don't get that
nowhere else so you get the qualified
candidates you need fast I don't care
whether you have a plumbing business or
whether you got a business of 200 more
zip recruiters for you no more sorting
through the wrong resumes no more
waiting for the right candidate to apply
it's no wonder zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the US this
rating comes from hiring sites and
Trustpilot with over a thousand reviews
and right now the church family could
try zip recruiter for free listen to me
I just told you to try super cool for
free at zip recruiter backslash Church
that CH you are CH that zip recruit comm
slash Church CH you are CH give it a
shot it's the smartest way to high
I want to thank Felicia Michaels I want
to thank the [ __ ] Lisa at most
importantly I want to thank you guys I
want to thank 23andme I want to thank
sip recruiter and tushie for sponsoring
the episode but you guys have been
[ __ ] family to the end I see you guys
Thursday morning ready to rock I'll see
you [ __ ] in New York Thursday
night ready to [ __ ] rock
great Monday have a great week stay
black don't let nobody [ __ ] with you
right Tom uncle Joey sent you kick that
[ __ ] mealy